At the age of nine,
he knew what he wanted to do with his life and he never wavered from that goal.
Now he's one of the world's most famous scientists.
He's earns the title of most powerful nerd in the universe from national public
radio and the title of the world's sexiest astro physicist from people magazine.
He was also instrumental in cutting down the number of planets in our solar
system and in doing so he upsets and entire generation who would come to love
Pluto.
Who as the small crikey planet and as well who is this icon of science that's
recognizable by the general populous?
Well,
of course it's Neil degrasse Tyson.
Okay.
Dyson was born in New York City in 1959 and he grew up in the Bronx.
His mother worked for the U S Department of Health,
education and welfare and his father worked for the city of New York,
Tyson.
He was a star student at the Bronx High School of Science.
Well before beginning at the Bronx High School of Science,
they'd Tyson had decided that science was the path that he wants to follow with
his life.
When he was an elementary school.
So essence class took a field trip to the Hayden Planetarium.
While that he felt that he was literally calls to a career in science,
so strong was that in brands of the night sky that I'm certain that I had no
choice in the matter that in fact the university called me twice and immediately
began committing time to his new found interest and some might say obsession and
his time in high school showed his dedication to the study of the stars while
attending the Bronx High School of Science.
Tyson was a wrestler,
but he devoted much time to his studies.
He was the editor of the physical science journal Man's regular classes.
They weren't enough for him.
He actually took classes at the very place that sparked his interest in
astrophysics,
the Hayden Planetarium afterschool.
He spent time observing the sky and the moon,
the stars all from the roof of his home in New York.
His dedication to science and academics during his teenage years grabbed the
attention of some very prominent people.
One of these,
well,
you might've heard of him as Carl Sagan.
When it came time for Tyson to apply to college,
Cornell,
it was among the schools that he applied to.
The Sagan was a professor at Cornell and the admissions office made sure he was
sent a copy of Tyson's application after they saw the talent and potential that
was within this aspiring scientist.
Sagan was duly impressed by what Tyson had written in his application.
So much so that he invited Tyson.
Just spend a day at Cornell to Iceland.
He remembers that day in 1975 it's one of the most formative days of his life.
Sagan,
well,
he died in 1996 and Tyson came into possession of his dates work,
which includes the notation Neil Tyson on the square for December the 20th 1975
the two science minded men spend the day together touring Cornell's labs and
discussing the mysteries of the universe so you can gifted Tyson with a copy of
the book,
the cosmic connection inscribing.
It's to indicate his prediction and hope for Tyson's career to a future
astronomer.
Tyson never forgot.
He learns from Seguin that day and the lessons he took back to the Bronx.
With him,
we're more than just the scientific method.
I already knew I wanted to become a scientist,
but that afternoon I learned from Carl the kind of person I wanted to become.
He reached out to me and to countless others,
inspiring.
So many of us just study,
teach,
and do science.
Science is a cooperative enterprise spanning the generations.
A few months after his visit,
Cornell Tyson and graduated from the Bronx High School of Science,
even though his visit with sake and had a profound impact on his life,
Tyson opted not to attend Cornell,
but as an excellent students.
He had no shortage of prominence goals to choose from.
Though Cornell wasn't the right fit for him.
Harvard was Tyson entered Harvard as an undergraduate in the fall of 1976 as a
student.
He paid his tuition partially through grants and scholarships,
but also through a work study program.
Part of Tyson's work requirements was to clean bathrooms on campus,
including those of the other students on eight Neri King live appearance.
He described the experiences a little weird that he was willing to do it to pay
his way through school and to achieve his dreams working and study in physics
when enough to occupy the active and curious Tyson though he was on the crew
team and the wrestling team while he was at Harvard and he was also a jazz
ballet and Latin dancer.
He graduated from Harvard in 1980 with a degree in physics and kept his academic
career moving forward with an acceptance to the University of Texas for a
masters program.
He completed his MBA in astronomy in 1983 and he intended to pursue a doctorate
from the college,
but well,
here's a roadblock and Tyson himself admits that the roadblock with largely of
his own making looking bag,
he has admitted that he didn't devote as much time to doing lab research during
his graduate years as he should have and could have and this prevented him from
being able to go right from his master's program to earning a doctoral degree.
He even had professors tell him to stop working in the field of astronomy.
At one point struggling as a student and it's broke.
Tyson considered a very different job than that of a professor.
Royal Museum director.
He thought about becoming an exotic dancer.
He even went so far for us to go to a show to see if he could do it.
When the dancers came out and their skimpy undergarments were lit up as they
join Rita do a rendition of great balls of fire to ice and decided that no
matter how broke he was exotic dancing.
Well,
it wasn't very am thankfully for the scientific community.
They Tyson's break from academics.
It was short lived with his undergraduate achievements and a start and a
graduate degree.
He was able to land a teaching job at the University of Maryland's and
eventually he found his way back onto the doctoral track in the Ivy League in
1991 15 years after scrubbing toilets to pay for his undergraduate degree to
Iceland,
graduated from Columbia University with a doctorate in astrophysics.
He then studied in the Ivy League system moving to Princeton for a postdoctoral
position
while he was earning his degrees and moving his way up the academic ladder.
Tyson was publishing articles and writing a column for date,
a Science magazine published by the University of Texas.
While he was attending Columbia,
he also worked under a professor who was supportive of Tyson's ambitions and
intellect,
applying for grants that gave Tyson access,
do the international astronomy community,
Tyson.
He traveled throughout Europe attending meetings and learning from the best and
brightest in the field from all around the world at Tyson's own star.
It was awesome getting to rise soon after graduating from Columbia.
Well,
he landed his dream job and yep,
that was a position back at the Hayden Planetarium.
Whereas dreams that started,
he started out as a staff scientist,
but it was after one year that he was named acting director of the planetarium.
Then only one more year later,
he was formerly named the director of the Hayden Planetarium.
Early on in his tenure in director,
he made updating and modernizing the facility,
a keystone of his work at Hazen,
the project.
It was a $200 million undertaking.
The gate of the public,
a modernized invoicing look into the vastness of the universe and his work well.
That extended way beyond the planetarium.
In 2001 he received a presidential appointment to work on policies related to
the future of the u s space industry.
After that,
he was part of a commission to work on the future of space exploration is
serving on these committees was so impressive that NASA gave him the
distinguished public service medal,
Tyson's scientific work,
as well as decisions he made about the Hayden Planetarium puts him in the
spotlight for the general public well beyond those.
Normally in the scientific community.
He actually became a household name because of one particular decision and to
what?
What did he do?
Well,
he removed the planet of Pluto from the planetariums are solar system display
school from parents and scientists are like,
well,
I'm not impressed with this decision,
and soon it became more about just the planetariums displayed please hose fate.
It was taken up by an international organization,
the International Astronomical Union in 2006 the organization made their stance
on Pluto official when they deemed Pluto a dwarf planet officially knocking our
solar system down to having only eight planets.
So well,
the question might be now,
well,
what does Tyson maintain is so wrong with Pluto?
Well,
for one,
it has the potential to grow a tail.
Yes,
that is a legitimate reason.
And hit is the man himself explaining us.
So Pluto is not the littlest planet or rice.
That's a loan.
It shouldn't it.
But more than half of its volume is ice.
No other planet has that.
So if you moved it to two where earth is right now,
heat from the sun would evaporate the ice and it would grow a tail.
That's no kind of behavior for a planet answered as Pluto's orbit is much more
elongated than that of the other planets.
And it's so small.
But the other planets have moons that are larger than Pluto.
And you're beginning to see why he falls on the Pluto is not a planet side of
the fence.
Now,
the police thing was one of the most famous,
maybe infamous scientific assertions of Tyson's career.
Indeed,
he has written articles,
essays,
and even books that discuss in much more detail the demotion of this planet,
how they spoke to us.
He wrote for National History magazine and the 1990s in his columns were later
into two different books.
These were at death by black hole and astrophysics for people in a hurry.
He chose the pen name of Merlin for himself when he wrote a column in the start,
a magazine and those columns,
they will also later published as books.
Okay.
Tyson hasn't just used publications do you spread the word about science and the
universe?
He's hosted TV shows.
He regularly appears as a guest on other shows and he has his own podcast called
startalk.
He hosted at Nova Science now in the mid two thousands raising his profile even
further to most Americans.
He was so popular as a host that in 2014 the where I brought him back to delve
even further into science for the American people,
the 2014 to show,
gave Tyson and opportunity to build on the work of a man who had impacted him
early on.
And that would be Carl Sagan.
Well actually it was cosmos,
a new version of the popular on that Sagan.
It hosted in the 1980s at the time of its air and cosmos was the most watched
show in the United States.
But if there was anyone who could live up to these kinds of expectations,
well and that would be Tyson.
He didn't have to go to loan in 2014 though he had the help of sagans widow who
worked as a right of the cosmos.
And the two made sure to include illusions to sagans work throughout the rebuke
did series the series,
it was a success and over 3 million Americans put their TV on to Fox to catch
the newest science lesson presented by Tyson every Sunday for 13 weeks because
of us.
Reboot was undoubtedly successful.
And showed Tyson's appeal to the general populace,
but his appeal in the media,
well,
it goes well beyond direct and serious science.
He's appeared as a guest on family guy,
Brooklyn nine nine and his character in new ice age.
The Big Bang theory with it's nerdy cast has of course welcomes Tyson as a
guest.
He even made an appearance on avenged sevenfold Zalman the stage he didn't sing
but instead delivered a monologue during one of the band's songs and musical at
Aaron's that was remits happened that never actually came about was that Tyson
would appear on an album with whoops hand clang member [inaudible] though the
appearance never happens.
It does speak to Tyson's breadth of talents and popularity that many people
thought it was a very profitable thing for Tyson to do while the album didn't
happen.
Tyson hinges or did appear together,
which is a wrapped on startalk.
Even the daily show is regularly featured Tyson to comment on science matters
and as he did with Pluto,
Tyson makes no bones about sharing his thoughts on what needs to be corrected.
Indeed a blight on area informed John Stewart,
the beginning of your program,
the Earth is spinning the wrong direction.
I'm sorry,
I had to get that off my chest.
The Earth on the credits were spinning clockwise.
When earth really spins counterclockwise,
though Tyson pointed it down to Stewart and the entire viewing audience.
It wasn't until Trevor Noah took over as host in 2015 that the show made a
permanent correction to the earth spinning direction.
Tyson was excited about the change in the tweet and artists,
thanks to the daily show.
The daily show is globe isn't the only correction that Tyson's scientific
knowledge has led to in the realm of pop culture.
While you might remember that 97 blockbuster movie,
titanic,
well,
Tyson sore it anti wasn't impressed near the ends.
Off to the ship was sunk.
Rose's lying on a board in the freezing Atlantic Ocean.
She's gazing up at the night sky as the audience can see what she sees the stars
in the sky over the ocean.
When Tyson saw that scene,
he noticed something that the rest of us didn't.
While the styles,
they weren't in the road arrangement for the year in 1912 at the latitude and
longitude where the titanic sunk.
So as with the daily show,
Tyson lets director David Cameron know according to Cameron,
Tyson's and Timmy snarky email on the subject.
15 years after that film was first released Cameron and took Tyson suggestion
and adjusted the night's going in that scene in order to be accurate as titanic
in the daily show weren't enough for Tyson.
These even how to hands in keeping Superman's scientifically accurate.
DC comics wanted to feature the world's most famous astrophysicist and a comic
that's Tyson wouldn't do it unless he could be sure of the accuracy with the
distance.
Krypton is supposed to be from Earth at Tyson said he would never be able to
help.
Superman's spot it.
It's like,
well what did he do?
Well,
he did his research and found an actual red star to serve as crips on and
crafted a story whereby superman would combine all the telescopes on earth to be
able to see Krypton.
So no media format has been untouched by Tyson.
The man is everywhere.
Spreading the word of science and the people of the world.
Well,
we're listening.
Creators and producers take his advice and seek him out for appearances among
scientists.
He is unique in this kind of stardom.
A serious scientist and pop culture figure would seem to make any person
interesting enough.
But Tyson has hobbies and interests that go well beyond the mysteries of space
and the sharing of science.
He and his wife Alice,
who he maps in a physics class,
I'll go foodies.
Tyson has said that they probably spend too much money on food,
but living in Manhattan,
they have so many restaurants to explore and so many food options to try out
that they take every opportunity they can to try new foods.
So Iceland,
he's also a wine connoisseur.
His love of science plays a big role in his enjoyment of wine helping him.
Do you understand why different wine tastes different and how they best can be
served like much else?
Tyson explains these concepts simply so that nonscientists can understand them
to the lower than 32 degrees.
Freezing points of liquids that contain alcohol.
Like wine allows you to chill a bottle of white wine to sub freezing
temperatures without it freezing before you bring it to a dinner party.
The wine warms up during the travel time to just the right temperature in time
for dinner in dd rather well known scientist is the source of Tyson's favorite
quote about food and wine and that would be Galileo.
The Sun.
With all those planets revolving around it and dependent on it can still write
them a bunch of grapes as if it had nothing else in the universe to do food,
wine,
physics.
Well,
what's left for him to care about and learn about?
calligraphy for one Tyson can create beautiful letter dart with a feathered pen,
but is especially passionate about fountain pens.
He loves them so much that his wife has spent a $6,000 to buy him.
A Japanese made Penn as a gift when you finalize the contracts on his
autobiography.
He even gave an entire interview to the New York Times on the pen and his love
of calligraphy.
In the interview.
He described his own mathematical theory behind how you can tell if a pen is
perfect for calligraphy.
Having to dip the pen in in calf to every eight to 10 words means you're writing
with a beautiful rhythm.
He says
he's passionate about life and everything in it.
He's passionate about science and the world knows it.
With all this he's accomplished in his life and the celebrity status he's
achieved.
It would be easy to excuse Tyson for having a large ego,
but he doesn't.
In fact,
you take special pains to point down to the danger of ego if you already go
starts out,
I am important.
I am big.
I am special.
You're in for some disappointments.
When you look around what we have discovered about the universe.
No,
you're not big.
you're not.
You're small in time and space and do you have this frail old vessel called the
human body that's limited on earth.
Perhaps this attitude is a large part of his success and why he is so beloved
for all his intelligence and his contributions to the study of space.
Neil degrasse Tyson remains firmly planted with two feet right here on earth.
So I really hope you enjoyed the video.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos every Monday and Thursday.
And if you've got a suggestion for us,
would you like to see us make a biographics video about someone in particular?
Well,
please do join it and then the comment section below and let us know what you
thought of this video as well.
We're always looking to improve and make these videos better,
and we can only do that with your help and feedback.
So please do get involved in the comments and does it always.
Thank you for watching.